[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
Clara is up in Louisville Kentucky Clara
how can we
help hey guys I am thrilled to be able
to talk to you guys well we are thrilled
to talk to you what's happening yay I
have a question more for Jade my money
girl um okay I'm gonna I'm gonna smoke a
Sig while you guys talk this will be
great
okay we are looking at buying a house
next year um um and we want to know if
we're crazy or if we we're rushing into
it or if our numbers are looking okay in
what order we need to do things so tell
me more right now we have um
$6,200 um on a credit card okay 7,000 on
a truck and then a
$20,000 home equity line of credit okay
um within the past since August we've
paid off $34,000 in credit card debt
good so we're we're on a roll um and my
goal is to have the credit cards and the
truck paid off by March okay um and then
I didn't know do
I not pay on the home well I pay the
minimum payment on the home equity line
of credit and um do our three to six
months emergency savings and then when
we sell our house pay that off and still
have 20% to put down on the new house I
pay it off
I'd work to paid off for two reasons a
it's less than half of the value of your
home I'm
guessing like it's less than
half yeah we owe 124 on our house and we
could sell it for 230 yeah because it's
less than half of that 124 I'd go ahead
and pay it off and here's the thing if
you don't pay it off it's going to cut
into your your winnings right when you
sell the house right so you may as well
pay it off so that money goes right back
into your pocket again it's that idea of
a forced you're forcing yourself to save
the money by paying off this 20,000 does
that make sense okay you're get need we
still need the 3 to six months before we
buy or can we take that out of the um
what we make on the
house um again it's what you're saying I
see what you're saying but you need to
get the three to six months in place
first and then when you sell the house
that money is going towards the next
house okay just that chunk goes straight
toward the next house cuz you're going
to need it right well how much are you
trying to put
down um well we would only need about
70,000 to put down uh the house we're
looking at is around 300 and how much
sorry you told me this but I missed it
when you sell the house how much will
will it bring in
total uh
230 no no no how much will you take home
we should have oh um we should have
about 110 110 so you're saying and
that's after Fe is that after fees and
you've considered all that no that's
before okay so let's consider fees and
let's let's knock off 15 all right and
let's say that you let's say you bring
home 95 so you're saying hey we don't we
didn't we never plan to put that full 95
down and we can take some of that and
put it as our emergency
fund right well what what we still have
the
20% listen the way my mind works I'm
like I want to put the full 95% down or
the full 95,000 down
90 okay how long will it take you to
save up 3 to six
months um maybe two months I would
listen
listen save up that three to six months
it's all the same you know what I'm
saying it's a big pool of money and I
see what you're trying to do you're kind
of trying to shift it so you can move
faster I I would rather you have that
extra $15,000 to put down on this
mortgage it's okay in the long run
you're going to thank yourself for it
and it's only G it's not like it'd be
one thing if you said Jade it's going to
take us six more months to save up or
another year to save up that'd be maybe
a little different I might change my
answer maybe not but um in this case
it's two months like just wait two
months right you know and then you've
got more money you've got $155,000 more
in your pocket and that's going to go
towards your mortgage I love that
idea okay all right well thank you
you're welcome my problem CL did you get
what you needed from Jade you needed me
anything from me at all I mean anything
nothing your cigarettes gone out I don't
think I do oh great I see how we I see
how this is Clara oh Merry Christmas I
see how this is uh no we love you Claire
thank you very much Merry Christmas yeah
she didn't want to ask me anything
listen Ken and that sweater I get it I
know I think it's intimidating you know
it puts off a uh puts off the wrong Vibe
I guess very it's very intimate create
your free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life